WE WANT TO TAKE YOU TO FORT
MYERS, FLORIDA.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS A CNN
DRONE LIVE SHOT AND SHOW YOU
SOME OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING
AS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET UP
ABOVE THE AREA TO LOOK.
JUST LOOK AT THE DEVASTATION
YOU'RE SEEING RIGHT THERE.
I MEAN, YOU'VE GOT DEBRIS
EVERYWHERE, WATER AND MORE
WATER.
ROOFS PEELED OFF
INDISCRIMINATELY AND ALSO SEEING
AS YOU GET CLOSER, YOU CAN SEE
THE SHORELINE TO YOUR RIGHT.
YOU CAN SEE BOATS HAVE BEEN
THROWN ALL OVER THE PLACE.
JUST LOOK AT THE TREES, TORN
APART.
AS THIS DRONE CONTINUES ON
THROUGH, REALLY SHOWING JUST
SOME OF THE DEVASTATION THAT HAS
BEEN DESCRIBED TO US OVER AND
OVER AGAIN OF THE HIT THAT FORT
MYERS HAS TAKEN.
WE KNOW THAT SO MANY RESCUES
HAVE BEEN REQUIRED.
WE WERE JUST TALKING TO THE
COAST GUARD AND THAT THEY'VE
BEEN DOING AIR AND WATER
RESCUES.
PEOPLE NEEDING TO BE RESCUED
FROM THEIR ROOFTOPS, FROM WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN DEALING WITH AND
YOU CAN SEE, YOU JUST HOPE THAT
SO MANY OF THESE FAMILIES GOT
OUT, GOT TO SAFER GROUND, GOT TO
HIGHER GROUND, OF COURSE, AS
THIS STORM WAS BARRELING
THROUGH.
THOSE STREETS STILL COVERED WITH
WATER.
YOU SAW ANOTHER IMAGE, ANOTHER
SHOT THAT THE DRONE HAD JUST A
MOMENT AGO, BOATS CAPSIZED,
THROWN ABOUT, LOOKING MORE LIKE
TOYS THAN HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS OF BEAUTIFUL BOATS.
PIERS JUST TORN APART.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER IMAGE OF
WHAT, UNFORTUNATELY, WILL BE
MANY THAT WILL BE COMING IN AS
LIGHTS COMING UP, COMMUNE
INDICATIONS ARE MORE ESTABLISHED
AND WE'RE GETTING A BETTER IMAGE
OF WHAT EXACTLY WE'RE LOOKING AT
IN SOUTHWEST FLORIDA AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE, EVEN
FURTHER INLAND NOW AS WE ARE
LEARNING.
JOINING ME NOW IS CORY ADAMSKI.
I KNOW YOU COULDN'T GET YOUR
VEHICLES OUT OR SOME OF YOUR
EQUIPMENT OUT YESTERDAY.
ARE YOU ABLE NOW TO GET OUT AND
ABOUT AND CONDUCT RESCUES?
>> YES, WE'VE BEEN OUT AND ABOUT
THROUGH MOST OF THE CITY.
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF AREAS STILL
INACCESSIBLE DUE TO LARGE TREES
OR DEBRIS DOWN BUT ACTUALLY HAVE
OUR PERSONNEL AS WELL AS PRIVATE
CONTRACTORS AND THEN OUR
COMMUNITY SERVICES WITH HEAVY
MACHINERY WORKING ON GETTING
ACCESS TO ALL THOSE AREAS OF THE
CITY.
>> THANK GOODNESS FOR THAT.
WHAT ARE THE CALLS THAT ARE
COMING IN?
>> YOU KNOW, WE GET A WIDE
VARIETY.
WE'RE GETTING PEOPLE REPORTING
POWER LINES DOWN AND WATER
LEAKS, GAS LEAKS, MANY OTHER
UTILITY ISSUES AND THEN WE'RE
GETTING CALLS FOR WELFARE CHECK,
PEOPLE THAT HAVEN'T HEARD FROM
FAMILY MEMBERS, UNFORTUNATELY,
SOME RECEPTION IS STILL PRETTY
SPOTTY RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE GETTING REGULAR MEDICAL
CALLS WE ANTICIPATE EVERY DAY SO
IT'S A GOOD MIX OF EVERYTHING.
>> WELL, AND PEOPLE ARE VERY
THANKFUL TO SEE YOU COMING TO
CHECK ON THEM.
WE HAVE SEEN VIDEO POSTED OF
YOUR FIREHOUSE KIND OF INUNDATED
WITH WATER.
WHAT HAPPENED?
HOW FAST DID THAT SURGE COME IN?
>> SURE, SO WE WERE ACTUALLY
RUNNING CALLS AS THE STORM MOVED
IN FOR THE PUBLIC.
WE WERE RUNNING CALLS FOR
VEHICLES THAT WERE STUCK IN
LOW-LYING AREAS.
MEDICAL CALLS AND WE ACTUALLY
LEFT THE STATION FOR A CALL
ABOUT 20 MINUTES PRIOR TO WATER
MOVING IN REALLY QUICKLY.
WE GOT DISPATCHED TO ANOTHER
CALL, PULLED OUT AND WE WILL
REALIZED WE'RE GOING TO FLOOD IF
WE DO TRY TO PULL OUT OF THE
STATION SO MADE A DECISION TO
BACK IT BACK IN, CLOSE THE DOORS
AND HOPEFULLY SHELTER IN PLACE
AND PREVENT IT FROM CERTAIN
FLOODING.
THE STATION IS DESIGNED FOR WET
THE BAY AREAS ARE LOWER THAN THE
FEMA FLOOD PLANE BECAUSE OF
BEING ABLE TO GET OUT.
THEN WE ENDED UP WITH ABOUT
3 1/2 WATER INSIDE THE BAY OF
OUR STATION.
>> I SPOKE WITH THE MAYOR, THE
MAYOR OF NAPLES EARLIER THIS
HOUR, AND THE WAY SHE DESCRIBED
IT.
SHE'S NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS AND WHAT NAPLES IS GOING TO
BE LOOKING AT IS CATASTROPHIC
AND DEVASTATING.
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE IT?
I MEAN, YOU GUYS ARE OUT SEEING
THIS FIRSTHAND AS YOU'RE TRYING
TO CHECK ON PEOPLE AND HELP
PEOPLE?
>> IT'S CERTAINLY DIFFERENT THAN
ANY OTHER STORM THAT ANYBODY
THAT IS WORKING HERE NOW HAS
SEEN.
WE HAVE IRMA FIVE YEARS AGO AND
IT WAS VERY DIFFERENT FROM THIS
STORM.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN A STORM SURGE IN
WATER LIKE THIS EVER REALLY THAT
WE KNOW OF.
SO WE'RE WORKING WITH A LOT OF
EQUIPMENT TO TRY TO GET ROADS
OPEN.
A LOT OF DEBRIS, BOATS WERE
THROWN ONTO ROADS, VEHICLES, SO
WE'RE MAKING A GOOD EFFORT
GETTING EVERYBODY BACK
ACCESSIBLE TO THE
CNN'S RANDY KAY HAS BEEN TOURING
THE DEVASTATION LIVE FOR US.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING?
>> Reporter: WE ARE IN DOWNTOWN
FORT MYERS.
THIS IS DOWNTOWN, THESE ARE THE
STREETS THAT WERE COMPLETELY
FLOODED YESTERDAY, AND HERE'S
WHAT WE FOUND.
THIS IS A PIECE OF SEAWALL.
JUST LOOK AT THE SIZE OF THIS.
WE ARE A FEW BLOCKS OFF THE
WATER.
SO THAT'S HOW FAR THIS TRAVELED
AND THOSE PIECES BACK THERE
TRAVELED IN THE WATER.
AND YOU CAN IMAGINE THE FORCE
THAT IT WOULD HAVE TAKEN FOR
THIS KIND OF PIECE OF STONE TO
MOVE.
AND IF YOU JUST LOOK AT DOWNTOWN
FORT MYERS, THERE'S METAL THAT'S
BEEN STREWN AROUND, THERE'S MORE
PIECES OF CONCRETE AS WE WERE
DRIVING THROUGH.
NONE OF THE STOPLIGHTS ARE
WORKING.
THERE'S STOP SIGNS THAT ARE
DOWN.
HERE IS MORE DEBRIS.
THIS IS GOING TO TAKE QUITE SOME
TIME.
ALL THE WAY OVER HERE, ANOTHER
GIANT PIECE OF SEAWALL.
TREES DOWN ALL OVER DOWNTOWN.
IT IS SUCH A MESS HERE.
AND ALSO ON THE WAY WE HAD TO
CROSS A BRIDGE, AND THERE WAS --
I DON'T KNOW, HALF A DOZEN,
MAYBE A DOZEN BOATS THAT HAD
ALSO BEEN LOST IN THE STORM.
THEY WERE JUST PILED RIGHT ON
TOP OF EACH OTHER.
BUT WE ALSO SPENT A LITTLE BIT
OF TIME IN NORTH FORT MYERS, WE
WERE IN THIS COASTAL COMMUNITY,
AND THEY WERE COMPLETELY FLOODED
BY THE CALOOSAHATCHEE RIVER, AND
THE PICTURES THERE, THE PEOPLE
THAT WE SPOKE WITH, WE SPOKE
WITH ONE WOMAN, AN 85-YEAR-OLD
WOMAN, WHO SAID IT TOOK SECONDS
FOR THE WATER TO COME UP TO
SHOULDER HEIGHT.
SHE WAS TOSSED AROUND WITH
FURNITURE IN HER OWN HOME.
IT WAS BEING FLOODED, SO IT
THREW HER UP AGAINST THE WALL.
SHE WAS TAKEN TO THE HOSPITAL BY
A NEIGHBOR.
IT WAS REALLY ALL ABOUT
NEIGHBORS HELPING NEIGHBORS.
THE FIRE TEAMS WERE THERE THIS
MORNING.
THEY WERE DOING SOME SEARCH AND
RESCUE THIS MORNING.
NO FATALITIES, AT LEAST AS OF
NOW IN THAT COMMUNITY.
IT REALLY IS ABOUT NEIGHBORS
HELPING NEIGHBORS AND NOW THEY
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO.
WHAT DO YOU DO IN A CITY LIKE
THIS.
YOU HAVE TO PUT IT BACK
TOGETHER, BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
THESE PEOPLE WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
HOMES, THEY HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DIG OUT, DRY OUT AND WHAT
THEIR NEXT STEPS ARE.
>> RANDI, YOU MENTIONED YOU'RE
IN THE CITY CENTER NOW, MORE OF
A BUSINESS DISTRICT.
YOU WERE IN A RESIDENTIAL AREA
IDEA.
WE WILL HAVE THROUGHOUT THE HOUR
ALL OF THESE STUNNING STATISTICS
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, ONCE IN A 1,000
YEAR FLOODING, HOW MUCH WATER
WAS DUMPED ON FLORIDA.
YOU HAVE DONE THIS FOR YEARS.
YOU HAVE CONSIDERABLE
EXPERIENCE.
JUST FROM YOUR OWN EYES AND
WALKING THROUGH THESE
COMMUNITIES, IN TERMS OF THE
PUNCH SOUTHWESTERN FLORIDA HAS
TAKEN, DESCRIBE IT.
>> Reporter: IT'S A SEVERE
PUNCH.
IT'S A KNOCKOUT, TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE WE SPOKE
WITH THAT HAVE NEVER SEEN A
STORM LIKE THIS.
WE WERE ON THE BACK SIDE OF IT
LAST NIGHT.
I'VE NEVER EXPERIENCED A STORM
LIKE THIS, HAVING LIVED IN
FLORIDA FOR YEARS NOW AND
COVERED HURRICANES.
BUT MANY OF THESE PEOPLE WE
SPOKE WITH THIS MORNING, THEY
HAVE LIVED HERE FOR YEARS AND
THEY'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
IT.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT A WALL
OF WATER COMING THROUGH,
BREAKING THROUGH WINDOWS,
BREAKING DOORS DOWN.
THEY WERE SCREAMING AND MANY OF
THEM WERE RUNNING FOR THEIR
LIVES TRYING TO GET OUT OF
THERE.
THEY LEFT THEIR PETS AT HOME.
THEY WERE COMING BACK TO GET
THEM THIS MORNING.
IT WAS A REAL FORCE.
IT WAS A REAL VIOLENT STORM THAT
CAME THROUGH.
IT'S NICE TO SEE DOWNTOWN FORT
MYERS, AT LEAST, IS COMING
ALIVE.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT.
THERE'S A PIZZA PLACE OPEN.
FLORIDIANS ARE VERY RESILIENT,
THEY'VE LIVED THROUGH THIS
BEFORE.
THIS CERTAINLY WAS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ONES I'VE EVER SEEN AND
MANY OTHERS HAVE EVER SEEN.
>> THAT IS PART OF THE
HEARTWARMING PART, THE DAY
AFTER, WHEN PEOPLE COME TOGETHER
AND TRY TO HELP EACH OTHER.
RANDI KAY ON THE GROUND FOR US
IN FORT MYERS.
THANK YOU.